we haven't heard from or talked about
failed Arizona Republican gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake for a little while
that's a good thing we should all be
glad about that she has not gone away
and now as she is considering running
for Senate in Arizona she spoke to the
San Diego California County Republican
party group and she suggested that I'm a
new villain has entered she suggested
that run back election Services
illegally sabotaged or even sabotaged
her election and one of the things that
I want to explain here is
there are sometimes reports about this
type of thing that I don't think do a
good job journalistically so let me
first play for you what she said and
then I'll tell you more about it
election day happened and they were in a
panic and they said how do we stop this
middle-aged woman
who's hell-bent to shut down that border
how do we stop her
and they said we're gonna have to
sabotage election day that's exactly
what they did starting at 6 a.m the
machines did not work on Election Day in
Arizona
the machines and 60 of our our voting
locations didn't work
there were lines four to six hours and
it was primarily in the Republican areas
it was so bad but what happened was they
intentionally printed the wrong image on
the ballot
run back somebody said it you're
following aren't you everyone knows this
they intentionally printed the wrong
image on the ballot it jammed the
machines 60 everybody knows it guys for
some of the polling places all of them
mainly in the Republican areas didn't
work this was a disenfranchisement of
the voter that I've never seen this big
in my life so she's mixing multiple
different conspiracy theories and also
pretending as though this run back thing
hasn't already been debunked and that's
how a lot of these people operate
there's a really irresponsible thing
that sometimes will happen when Kerry
lake or others put out a conspiracy
theory that is new to some people media
will sometimes reprint it without
including the fact that it's already
been investigated it's already been
debunked in this particular case an
expert witness hired by Carrie Lakes
lawyers did at one point testify that
ballots were found printed with the
wrong size image by run by back election
systems but it's been investigated
already assistant Maricopa County
attorney Tom Liddy looked into it and
said even if the ballots were printed in
the wrong size as the witness claims it
wouldn't matter
he said the votes would have eventually
been counted anyway it wasn't an issue
in addition that would be partisan in
its effect in other words if there were
ballots printed on the wrong size paper
or whatever the claim is they would
equally affect Democratic and Republican
voters and all of these other things she
pulls into it there were 10 hour lines
or five hours there were lines at some
polling places for part of the day
sixty percent of the machines didn't
work no a few tabulators briefly didn't
work the Republican Party initially
filed suit and then said oh it's been
fixed to our satisfaction they pulled
the suit all of these things have been
debunked but it's targeted like a weapon
at people who don't know any better also
targeted like a weapon at people who
don't know any better continued claims
from Kerry Lake that God wants her to
keep fighting for this election she lost
[Applause]
when they steal our vote
we're not going to have a country
believe me let me tell you there's I've
been a couple days I wanted to lay in
the fetal position in bed I'm not gonna
lie I'm a strong woman but there's been
a couple days where I just said I don't
want to do this
and God just kicked my butt out of bed
and said get back out there I put you in
this for a reason I didn't put a weak
person in this fight now of course it
seems it would have been easier for God
to prevent all of this if he wanted to
carry a lake to be the governor and just
have her win the damn election but God
works works in mysterious ways and we
don't know who prayed in in contrast and
Counterpoint and the prayer might have
canceled out who the hell knows it is
not stopping and she wants to
potentially continue this into 2024 with
a senate run that's very scary stuff